a daily Super blitz
less than 10
all right so
oh yeah three-minute chess here in 90
minutes of three chests of what 90
minutes of three-minute chess that's not
a good start
and I'm already looking to combat this
guy with this structure
a big question will be where's
gonna go
if he goes one then I have to be on the
lookout for efore
a bit more
all right I'm going here because I want
to meet Bishop there with Bishop c5 just
like this
this isn't our first time wrong right
here okay
so I'd be happy if I get the a file I
don't mind the double pawns and on this
probably I don't want to see B 4 so
let's just kill that idea I feel like
I'm maybe close to better here also this
might be a threat night here Queen B 4
could be strong and then if they take I
get the a file and if they don't take
then double isolated a palms okay well
we're moving forward and now I think I
kind of need to do something like this I
have to be on the lookout for a knight
move and then a fork now let's take here
and the reason for that I'm not sure
exactly well did I don't want a week in
this square want to keep him around so I
want to do this I could Castle though
after this move in a queen exchange I
probably maybe I don't even castle
here here
there's probably still too many pieces
around
just get my buck castled so queen queen
before Castle kingside
nothing
nothing too fancy so we're going to
start with that
that move huh
well let's just castle so where's this
guy going he could end up getting
trapped
chop-chop night here okay so he feels
like he's a bit stranded think I just
want to negate some pieces so my night
combats this night here also fights for
this square I stopped being a lookout
for this fork
let's put a ruck on a half-open file I
have this square so to be really careful
this is a it's a double pun but it's not
a pond that could be easily struck at
okay we're just going to cancel out this
night
I'm not throwing any punches I'm just
doing a whole lot of restriction as all
um yeah that move okay I'm gonna put
this night here
oh my god I totally missed that
what was I saying this pond can't be
easily attacked or something you
certainly can so I'm down upon I have a
I have a lot time it's the only thing
that I have gone for me maybe
all right I want to get rook to a3 in
and then double up
they're keeping me off balance all right
let's start with this
I guess here my bishop needs to have
some kind of retreat he could be trapped
yeah so uh I guess here they're gonna
flush my rouxelle and we're gonna keep
this mr. rook active
let's keep pressure on the a pond if the
knight moves maybe I have this one day I
I just I want to get the f5 square so
I'm giving up a pond all right so now
now this night could rely upon this
square and there's a punch and picking
up the pond back now so this should be
good for me let's throw them in a pin
there I just they're way down on time
also I'm just realizing you have some
rook checks
let's throw one in
just pick up upon this this night is a
monster
controlling everything
I feel like there should be mate right
around the corner they're looking to get
some pigs
let's just defend the one the one point
of attack right here yeah
they're just a little bit
slow but yeah I just completely
blundered the b4 pawn I didn't see that
long night maneuver I'm forgetting where
he even came from C 2 or D 3 D 3 yeah
when he went to d3 I was only fixated on
the c5 square
oh so yeah
at that game I'm not sure um I don't
know let's try d6 against cardigan 8000
not it's our second time plan let's see
what we get
think tank
hmm internet issue what's the story here
stunned by move to Knight f6
the old queen masters in the lead I'm
not sure what to add is just overtaking
Bruno 14 ah let's maybe peek over here
at the chat Bingham 7 1 7 thank you for
the sub fake it through grow mat the cat
as well three months in a row appreciate
the support
what is cardigan doing I'm getting as
Romeo's 88 and the twitch chat says
known a fried been a while
gilli wibble is in the chat
okay yeah I mean it is uh this is one of
those minus minus plus positions after
Knight f6
completely winning 14 black
I might have to try d6 more often
I was going to go for g6 some kind of
flexible setup
I guess we're going to be getting the W
here plenty of time a lot of lot of
people are on their third game already
okay yeah exactly J Bad's Knight f6 and
white is completely lost
all right it's 20 seconds and we'll see
who we get in round three I'll have fire
after this oh so Bruno 14 actually
reserved the first two games and he's in
a game with Queen master all righty
let's get back to tournament land
it happened there
I'm in 14th one who a good crew
one hundred and 161 are in here let's
see who we get somebody anybody
Ivy Tower is in there and there we go
alright let's try an e for a game
we got action I love it Sicilian okay
let's go Knights III first yeah I'm
gonna Fein keto hmm I'm still gonna
fiend cut out
I'm going to do this they have an
opportunity to
rune castling but I'm okay with a king
position here he's tucked in nice so how
do we go how do we improve let's start
with bishop here okay hands okay I'm
going to position my knight now I'm I'm
anticipating of course this being ket
also probably noticing a bit of a
pattern here with
the first game
I said this kills the Fein Khalid Bishop
doing similar right now let's go here
and I'm hung up
Knight c4 next let's just throw a jab at
the rook see what it wants to do I'm
gonna play here next anyhow oh okay well
this is an opportunity for a for because
a six can be met with this capture an
in-betweener
very important detail and I could go
into pac-man no what I was ready to drop
back I forgot I'm on the a pond now so
this is just winning they didn't see the
old in-betweener
so let's trade man
and throw a pig on the seventh
maybe two
what's the cleanest approach here let's
throw a punch at this rook trade is no
good because here at the end it's got to
go here and you know they just resigned
what could I do to follow up probably
just throw some ponds around many many
good approaches there I was looking for
something simple
and simple is usually trading pieces
when you're a material so
all right you got three and now third
still plenty of time a 90-minute
tournaments pretty good
yeah a one-hour tournament only get
about ten games in there but okay Bruno
I guess we'll try a caro-kann let's see
how they react to d5 okay I take with
the Jeep on more than the epon we're
gonna take with the e pawn in this one
a big downside with this is
there's now a healthy four versus three
for team light
but this the system is really simple to
play for black I feel that piece is just
kind of fallen really nice squares this
this pin can be really annoying
and they're kind of not sure what they
want to do I'm gonna go with this trick
here I want to keep this square open for
some pieces and now we do that
and how do we move forward from here
hmm
looking at c5 that's just look to double
yeah alright and from here all right
let's get this night doing something
they're moving really fast
isn't this a really annoying move
do I have any in-between shot probably
not let's just recap sure they're moving
very fast
I'll take once it forces one of their
pieces back and I want to have this
square open 99 here next yeah I'm making
some progress here let's do this
stop Knight here I don't want this night
to be challenged so easily
this is losing
9 2 d2 this is probably the first move
they thought of but they can't do that
and this is really weakening let's see
how they feel about this pressure let's
go here probably put the roof back ooh
that's a piece they offer to draw
I'm gonna play on I think I'm slightly
better here slightly better
just a hair better I'm get I'm getting
squares now a big one on d5 and how do
we steadily improve here let's kill the
night king f7
have a check
I feel like this isn't the cleanest
approach but it'll be good enough I
could do this take advantage of the pin
at stake
pins
that's gettin that's lookin fancy now
King takes we grab the rook there we go
I feel that team white is just playing
on out out of momentum let's scare that
night away got Bishop checks got Queen
checks queen mates that's gonna do it
probably just played a little too fast
there
Bishop to c3
I wasn't really too concerned about
double des that group of pawns GG pawns
tried D for a game first time playing
this guy alright grünfeld or not not to
King's Indian
I immediately closed it up
and okay so I'm happy about this
I go with the bishop I think he is
correct now let's go here let's keep the
pin
I may want to just castle a queen side
let's just over protect this square
and I think I want to start with this
idea and actually with that move I'm
basically saying I'm not going to be
castling queenside let's let's try to
get this in
and already and very fast
let's go all the way back mm-hmm okay
let's scare them away
let's grab some space it's typical
typical race position now I'm
threatening to win the night and I'm on
this I think I'm winning now still on
the night
this is a double pawn but
it's collapsing right Knight b6 I take
here and what is the queen not hitting
let's find out
yeah that night asked to move again and
these guys are following like dominoes
now can I pick him up
there's something better hmm let's pick
up the pawn probably just put a rope on
the c7 let's not think too long here
let's go with this one I don't want some
kind of capture and then the rook
entering so let's do this now
rook to b8 might have been interesting
let's take look
Knight c4
we're just going
her stuff
let's just keep pushing these guys and I
feel like I could just keep pushing
I go here I'm ready to take the rook
under a minute
I read you just take the rook now I
think so
I might have something fancy no not
quite the rook is hitting at b7
yeah these two are offset 40 seconds
left just keep pushing or right here
simplest make sure the Queen is off
I'll take care
you know not to
or to add I think it was winning after
okay now we're just taking the Queen
getting a queen and taking stuff
yeah after that night to a four move I
think it was goner
okay just know stalemates is all all
stalemates
fifteen seconds is plenty now stalemates
stalemates let's check that's going to
do it
yeah what what to really say with that
one I'm not sure I was just a little bit
faster on the queenside
that's all that that one came down to
let's try a c4 game
hmm I guess I'll feel
as well
let's go d3 I don't know I can't get in
d4 so I will I'll retain some
flexibility with my night with my e pawn
for one more move let's go for some fog
Vinik system I have to take extra care
over this square so that's why well both
of these would control this square but I
want to keep my off pawn free
let's get this in in Queen d2 they
should play Knight here now I think
that's a mistake they're supposed to
stop d4 so now at the end what's going
to happen is that this D pawn is pretty
vulnerable the natural defensive piece
would be a bishop on e7 but he's clearly
elsewhere so this is a big soft point
for team black
can't do this just yet he could be
flushed away b5 is very difficult to get
in so where will white be able to strike
okay I feel like I want to start with
just G or h3 Queen d2 and rook to d1
some very uh simple moves nothing
nothing flashy preventative stuff and
let's in let's get one more piece into
the action I'm holding off on f4 and it
is a committal move weakening to my
Kings side I think I like the approach
of not not even moving my off pawn how
about this let's just get rid of their
master defender
rarely is this a bad idea
Queen still on if they try to set up so
start to control some dark squares with
this now that the dark square Bishop is
removed d5 is weakened
she's gonna go here well I'm actually
throwing a punch of the night I was I
was gonna say I'm just doing this to
provoke Oh a weakness well I got a
weakness f6 so now they're seventh
ranked is weakened and maybe maybe an
approach with doubling on the D file is
good enough for me
I am also on this pawn
here's the other thing I have some space
so let's let's avoid the minor peace
exchanges still keep three of them
around they're stepping on one another's
toes so also with this knight on c6 the
bishops view and the Queen's view is
obstructed so he kind of gets in the way
now we're doubled up
and my night might look to get into F
form so what I'm doing right here is
just playing within the structure
more weakening moves I think I feel I
feel like I should be going in for this
now I'm ready to hit black with a fork
and a half
doesn't get any better than that
so Queen here Bishop here probably don't
want to get on the same files the rook
Wow
living on the edge man
look at that King Wow you got a lot of
guts man you got a lot of guts
still just take care it's just a funny
move to see King deaf six alright maybe
I'm not finished with putting pressure
on this pawn
9 to d4
all right
back on this oh they're not here
they left the game now they're back I
cut out for a second or two I don't have
any time and I take some intake with the
Queen
just put some pin
yeah I don't know what happened there
I'm not sure with the final
breakthrough was going to be for that
but hey it's pressing alright that first
half hour went by pretty quick 285 in
here I got 20
victor is up there three 20s okay
he's in a game top guys in a game here
okay Zhu Chen Lee it's a new account
haven't seen this account around all
right let's try night after 6:00 what do
we want to do all right
he liked to fianchetto um I already did
some system with this or I attempted to
do that on night there all right what's
the what's the idea
okay well I think that the deep on
belongs here
oh really all right well let's point at
this weakness now Bishop on f5 and I
actually have an opportunity to get rid
of their LightSquared Bishop and I'm
gonna I'm gonna do that right now if I
did here night here and then kind of
controls everything so there we go and
next step let's just uh let's go up with
the Queenie here all right let's take
let's develop the knight here it feels a
little bit awkward to do this because I
am blocking in my sea pond I just want
to kill that idea
secure my clean position basically
the other nights gonna jump in there
okay so we're gonna get the Queen's off
what do I have in this position let's
see they have a little bit of space
however I have the better bishop kind of
let's flush that night away I'm not
concerned that this is a some weakness
for my king position
because why
let's take him yeah cuz oh because the
Queen's are gonna be off any moment okay
you
come on
that bishop can actually be pretty
annoying and its sake here
yeah you know this isn't this isn't so
great for me
yeah my night is really just on the
defensive I have to look to restrict
that Bishop I'm worse here I am
definitely worse
gotta defend against
I do Bishop here doubling is fine
although yeah they miss played it there
now I have c5 if I get this move in and
I think I'm close to getting that in now
then there's some trouble also Bishop
here can be met with rook takes pawn
let's just recap sure okay so I think
we're close now take here yeah I have to
do that I'd like to didn't see that move
oh that's such
good move yeah that was a really good
move I am way on the defensive now
got to get my knight playing
thirty seconds
I'm going to take here
oh boy yeah this is this is very tough
King move here I have to push this pawn
I think I have to do this
yikes King here getting uh I think I
have to try that I
I was going to win that King and pawn
endgame
no time this might actually
if I had more time although another's
rook check and then rook there I only
had more time now this is a draw
you
cool
got away with one there that Bishop g5
move that's the that's the one that
really caught me off guard mm they're
very very lucky to pull a draw from now
and that way that was an excellent move
that they made there that was really
nice
rook back and then that in between they
didn't take the pawn straight away I
really like that move that was that was
very accurate I'm pretty sure that's a
best move because from there the end
result of that was what let's let's
throw this in the end result is that the
rooks got just way way way too active
and we're gonna take with the knight
maybe I maybe I win this bond its castle
first
hmm
okay let's go here actually
yeah here's the plan I'm gonna I'm gonna
go here try to provoke this and then
here maybe I jump into this square
yeah like this right now also here's the
other thing he's unprotected so if
they're making a night move to defend
here hang on I could already insert this
check I feel like this is even better
that's somehow okay so they're Kings
caught in the middle I'm leaning towards
III now and a quick route to e1 stuff
you
how do I make the most out of this
position this is one where I feel like
the computer just comes up with
something really direct
night check is my first thought
let's go with this and see how they
address this now unopposed dark square
bishop here drops this guy and I could
superglue this guy right in there
and I think I will
so I'm still looking at this let's do it
so the e-file or even the F file is
pretty appealing oh I don't even see
that they could Castle but I do have
this move on their queen oh I didn't see
that okay they resign
that was a quick one I'm extinguished
though no fire for 24 is 50 minutes left
okay it's still plenty of time 327 in
here I really liked that game that was
that was a really nice game that my
opponent played there
you know well not the not the opening
phase so much it was just just some kind
of playable stuff in the in the opening
but that middle game to end game area
that was nice
alright the rating eater
okay nye Dorf
what do we do how do we adjust this
bishop let's go here Bishop e7 and Queen
c7 and I hear you know here's the thing
I don't know too much about this opening
actually I do know something here you
need to take with the knight otherwise
you're gonna get hurt with captures here
and then captures here need to keep that
Bishop around so let's see we're going
down a very theoretical path and they
continue to
push let's go here I could take this
with check but I think there's some kind
of Queen here and they definitely get
some play I just want to address this
this point right here on these six this
is the critical line I'm pretty sure f6
and I get rocked back even more
I've been pushed right over in this line
more than once playing on the black side
so I would not be surprised if this
happens again but let's see what light
comes up with a capture is not the
critical move I'm pretty sure
um okay tempted to take this pawn now
no no no I'm not tempted to take that
phone now okay I'm taking enough upon I
need to make sure this night does not
kill me and this is still losing can't
do that
how about I give this night a shove yeah
and maybe maybe next I could play here
once he didn't though he's no longer
eyeing up this square I always have to
be on the lookout for that move by the
way I do have a counterpunching Bishop
to b7 oh I did not consider that move
well he has to be captured
he's got to go man
am I ready to weather this storm
probably not
maybe my night does something fancy
can my night save the day
here there's this hmm all right let's
see if they let me run away
my vision so I can't castle but maybe I
do this and then here I think this is my
safest bet
this is really tough to play as black I
know I'm off a piece but this guy's
still stuck in the middle it's not fun
it's not fun when you have to probably
find only moves and there's like a
million different attacking the most
routine light
yeah I know I know I know all right
let's go here in here we're castling by
hands my bishop negates the knight but
they might say no he's gonna be a goner
how can I take that guy
oh maybe I could snip this pawn now
maybe I want to get rid of this Bishop
before he hurts me no I like my knight
too much all right let's grab a pond I'm
not doing this just because I'm greedy
but I want the f6 squared
yeah that's no longer any that's no
longer hitting with check
so now this is a super bishop and maybe
my King King continues to run that's the
game plan this should be defendable now
honesty
about this poem
you
Queen here rook here Oh down to the wire
all right let's keep running King I'm
ready to blockade keep going King oh my
god I just dropped my rook he's been
he's he couldn't think after the
previous move oh man sorry about that
sorry about that yeah we just got a move
man maybe I could throw a threat one day
yeah we got we got something here I
think I don't know why did that move
oh I'm not the only one hanging pieces I
don't know what to think about that oh
man all right we got the boss again what
do we throw at the boss efore
okay
the alley Aachen I'm not gonna go with
any four pawns attack let's scare him
away first if I take here first and then
c-4 he has f6 so he's much more limited
by inserting c4 right now and only at
this point will I capture Queen here I
guess there's a way to sidestep the fork
with Queen e6 but let's see which one of
the ponds there take with okay so bit
more imbalanced
taking like that and I think I want to
I'm not sure I want to set up my pieces
probably this I'm anticipating some kind
of pressure against d4 so he's here I
don't have any concern about this but I
am I am concerned about d5 push and then
night C for hitting my bishop so
basically I want to get this move in and
a quick night to d2 I'm leaning more
towards Knight d2 than c3 because of
this very idea
um I still want to play c5
maybe maybe still this is correct and I
do give up my light square bishop and
then I get to push here I think this
must be the critical line they're not
even going for that and so I think I
think I'm just better now I have some
space I've gained a lot of time against
their Knight and let's put some pieces
on some nice squares now so actually I'm
going to hold off on making a developing
move because I want to make sure I can
maintain c5 so I want to meet b6 with B
form now I'll do this so that little
delay there with developing my bishop I
gave pause right there because I saw
some value and my c5 pawn I want to make
sure I can maintain him and that move
let's just cow so how about if I need
some more support on d4 I have this at
this maneuver let's start with this
Queen to d2 okay so they're Knight the
ninth and nine
how about we start with this eyeing up
this square he's going to jump in here I
see but here's the thing
what's the thing
let's do this I think this is now the
critical move maybe maybe the in a way a
forced move because I am ready to jump
in here and there's some nice strategic
ideas in mind without
mm-hm
I'm gonna go all the way home I wasted a
lot of time there I'm just gonna push me
around some more
they give up F form here okay I think I
need to release some pressure here they
could probably still do this
okay
I'm taking that night out and oh man I
just I have to jump in I'm dropping a
pond they've weakened their Kings side
let's see if that that means anything
now that I don't have a piece on f3 I
could kick the night out if he goes here
I have a queen h5 move I want to stop
this the night's gonna was he gonna do
he's gonna fee and keto this is probably
strong
preparing this he's gotta go I can't let
them clamp down okay right here oh I
gave them that move nice man
very nice
and take it's tough to accommodate
I got to get out of this bin let's try
to break down their structure get out of
the h2 square feels cozier over here
you bugger man you bugger yeah it's it's
kind of tough
kind of tough got that pond
defense man I need some D
Oh
we have three seconds
you
I'm down on time oh man I should have
been able to do some Mouse tactics oh
man
ah man I should have been able to kick
it into a higher gear
ah man that stings
I was so close so close to being able to
pre move out
man they earned that one though I got
outplayed in the middle game
I didn't quite have the timing down with
I had the right idea but the execution
was not well timed
okay where are we staying here whoo this
Victor is running away we can't let him
just run away like that all right
ah man so close all right Knight to f5
mmm that one's tough to shake off
okay do I take that dark square bishop I
really like my night
let's grab that guy
let's put a fish up here okay here's the
plan
boom boom boom now we'll go at this one
defend here in Knight to g4 so next
we're looking for these moves and let's
see how they this is this is the thing
that I wanted by taking out their Bishop
to be able to put pressure on d6 so
they're just uh pushing through huh
could do that and you could do that huh
let's start with this rook here I could
give the knight a shove or actually
where you would take first this is the
correct transformation we take first
give them an isolated pawn then we push
this might be a critical move okay they
didn't go for it and so spending a lot
of time again
all right you know what maybe I'm okay
even if this pawn goes here
yeah I was gonna do this and this kind
of stuff to blockade but they give up
some important squares to by pushing
namely for so and whenever he moves I
have another square I can maybe be
eyeing up
and that's a clean
a
they didn't even blink they didn't even
blink they're usually there's like some
like pause right there after you make a
blunder like oh what did I just do black
didn't even pause for a moment
that's funny not the blunder just like
the reaction you know what I mean like
normally there's a like you would take a
moment out oh what did I just do
my opponent doesn't do that though
it was all part of the plan hey let's
push that night
it's all part of the plan Queen a5
I am up a clean
I need I need to convert this fast
am i blending my queen no she's safe
just feels active no hesitation
I'll give the cleanup
I got a couple pieces that's good enough
let's take a pond it's on pin I can move
my bishop my knight is there
keep it really simple going after the
night next mama night
he's a gonner
my father has no quit man no quit okay
they do have some quit there we go we
got a W there 28 hi well we're not four
who is this guy man he's flawless Victor
28 32 minutes left there's definitely a
shot for second place that's for sure
first plate okay Eddie boss again the
boss beat me up last time it's the one
that I uh you know okay here we go so we
played in round one let's let's repeat
this gotta play faster against the boss
let's go here
same system
Challenge this night really soon let's
see how they react to it okay this
should be just excellent shouldn't here
let's do it
Bishop takes Queen takes I'm threatening
a win with 90 g4
let's go here maybe we do caveman stuff
maybe let's do it
throw the h-bomb h5
for see how they react I haven't
committed my King to the Kings side
clean side it is let's throw a punch at
where they're weak mm-hmm well that was
a convenient reply
defend him and I think I want to kind of
build something up in the center that
night is a bit annoying
all right I have to be careful about
this night move
Wow let's just back up I don't want to
take just yet
still want to watch over this this guy
this structure kills the bishop this guy
watches this let's see what happens here
this is probably useful
I gotta get the boss
I come in
to be eights at any point they could
initiate a chain reaction of captures
and this file can open up let's let's go
here right now they're gonna go to the C
file almost certainly
and I want to unpin as soon as possible
and guess here they're gonna play Bishop
here that could actually be annoying
although I have this move that's
convenient
hit the bishop defend there so now do I
take it also go here I kind of like this
move actually let's get here I want to
focus on this square and maybe I could
take over control let's go here
rook to c4 if I do this so I want to
keep this open for my knight
I'm not sure if this was the right idea
okay now we're gonna pin this night oh
man I missed that
I missed that idea I'm gonna jump in if
they kick my night away
let's jump in now I feel like I need to
stir up some trouble
they're ready to invade here I'd like to
get a passed pawn that's a strong move
hmm I have this move I think I do now
you hear I get to take the Queen wits
check what am I missing
I'm missing something he
it's scary let's see how this move works
I'm gonna repeat once is this move
working here there's a rook move but I'm
still on there bishop
man there's definite compensation
Bishop takes pawn the oh I'm on the rook
I'm on two pieces still I'm forgetting
ah man
ready to get mated rook there was a main
threat
I got to take here
I'm getting some stuff my Queens going
into pac-man mode
around the bishop and pond
you
oh my god this is so scary
you
oh my god Eddie boss
you are crazy fast Len holy cow that was
another coin flip
hmm
okay we got the W that was uh oh that
was a scary cave okay make a movement
don't lose on time let's try G six holy
cow
I got a I got away with a nut with
another one there
and still go for this setup so here I
need to try to resolve this tension
what's that move okay we've been here
before
should I grab that pun now let's go here
and here I want to open his eyes up
now's my opportunity hmm I'm gonna take
and let's see what's what's gonna happen
here takes takes then this is a
vulnerable point and they're not taking
so they're saying no give me a center
basically with that move
okay you got e4 ideal pawn Center
incoming no they don't I don't want to
do that so now if they're not playing e4
how do they get that in and they're
gonna try this do they have time to do
it I may do this no no no no we're not
gonna make a committal move we're gonna
stop
efore permanently and now c5 now let's
get another piece involved
Brook to be one clean here Bishop there
okay but now this is an opportunity to
break in the center
and I'll be taking with the night for
sure even though there's there would
only be one minor piece around this this
is still a really important piece with
the knight and queen they could I feel
that the knight in the Queen could work
some magic somehow with these dark
squares so it's definitely the night
capture
and here I'm in a pen but I don't really
see how that pin could be taken
advantage of so I'm not too concerned
about that
let's just go here they could they could
do this but I have a rookie I just want
to free up my queen is all I don't want
her having that responsibility anymore
so the C pawn is responsible for
defending my B pond we're gonna go here
Oh also here's the other thing I could
take this name because I'm on the Queen
should keep that in mind double
attacking the Queen so I could have done
that on the last no if I really wanted
but this should be simple enough get out
of the pin threaten the Queen welcome
exchanges in the end this guy's weak so
let's see
all right
um okay let's let's get some trades in
trade some more and we're on this at the
end so now they're gonna have to go on
the defensive they're not though let's
snip that guy
and to go into a prevent yeah I just
don't want to allow any activity Bishop
here I'll play off six that move babysit
he's the most important one work off
okay what are they trying to do here
I'm uh this looks extra passive and it
is but their their activity is temporary
so I could I could flush these guys back
actually you know I mean I don't think I
even need to do anything but just start
pushing pawns here I have
a boatload and let's welcome some
exchanges bishop there
I missed that move
I kind of
about that though let's just keep
pushing pawns
let's keep on going
now the clean
approach
you
actually let's do this now because here
I could do this and win the pond so now
my King is ready to play I have checks
its insert one
let's just go here ready do this and
then here let's do it
yeah these guys just March all on their
own let's just break them up
it's a little scary these kind of ideas
but it's but it isn't me it is a thought
I had thou my king was kind of limited
by moving up
if it was a bullet
I probably just run backwards at that
them up at that point just so I didn't
have to second-guess ur question am I
gonna get made it okay so where we are
less than 20 minutes left I'm in fourth
place thirty-four
still still possible for second place
okay so they're gonna take my queen and
give me the a file
and that move okay we're going to take
here I don't want to end up with an
isolated pond so
and I go one square just one
forget how I play I've had this position
before
not enough from this tournament but I've
had this structure before my opponent
seems to have had this structure before
as well let's go here
this is uh this is a strong night very
strong night I'll keep him around that's
not a good choice I don't think I take
away their best square okay and also at
this point I'm actually okay
I'm giving this square back up but they
straightened out my pawns now and I have
a tremendous amount of space that I
could look to still expand how do we
what's the correct I just want to take a
moment on I want to try to come up with
something here takes
yeah I'm gonna take and then kind of
let's do this
actually I don't want to see this break
this is a break I'm thinking black may
do at some point but then there's some
open lines over here where I could maybe
attack this guy I want to kind of pave
the way for my King to be on e4 I wasn't
really able to voice it before pulling
the trigger on this but kind of without
this break then the e-file isn't opened
up and I could rely bit more on the e4
square
um let's let's let's actually go for
this right now kind of put the King in
on the e4 square and I want to stop this
so if they try this it's not without
some weaknesses try for this kind of
advance let's put the king in the center
and if they double up they're
threatening a sacrifice on this square
chop chop check with the fork that could
be prevented though pretty easily so
Bishop c3 and now where do they go from
here
I don't okay let's let's try this and
then this move though they have that c5
advance what's up let's go here now that
they've released some pressure and this
I want to get in b5
let's do b5 now break it open I have I
have a 5 coverage so now my rook is
really active my rook could also help
defend like this
now right around this point I actually
think I want the bishop off
and my king is I love my king position
and my rook stops any other pawn breaks
without their dark square bishop around
to have any fear of dropping this guy so
from here I could look at this advance
also if they ever grabbed here I could
cut them off one day it's still tactical
I could cut them off and then look to
mate them if they go pawn hunting so now
this advance or what about just this and
then here doubling up and then with this
move to follow I totally missed that
move
Trax also I'm chewing up a ton of time a
ton of time I should have never moved my
my rope from b6 Brooke here I take and
then get behind my king is playing their
King is not playing
the wreck has to go back I could
probably take there but I
okay now am I going to win that pond
close now I am winning that
I don't like my execution and also
they're playing a lot faster now
technique
Wow
and now I'm just losing
Oh in the world did that happen
you
not cool man
I gotta try to time burn
Wow
they really played the end of that well
I got outplayed right at the end there I
liked how I played it up to a point and
then I just lost the thread when when
did I lose the thread I'll tell you one
as soon as they played b5 I totally
missed that they could set that guy into
motion and then uh I think I was still
better there but it affected it affected
mm give Lee it was still better but it
affected me psychologically there just
caught me off guard
so what am I doing here let's try rook I
don't want to come in my night I want to
still delay his movement because it
takes takes maybe one day I get into c6
so let's hold off on that now that move
okay
we're taking I have structures balanced
stuff in here I think I want to keep my
king right where he's at
structures balance but minor piece is
the big difference here and I'm cool
with going to two squares and then tuck
the bishop in right behind this is a
this is a fine setup rook here I just
want to I have one squared to really
look out for
then that is c5 so are they going to try
to do this
let's go here right now
this move I want to be able to take away
the c5 square so let's step up with the
queen keep open this possibility I have
a ideal pawn center and I could look to
expand let's do this move first though
maybe this here and then this would be
trapping the knight
okay so that move that really weakens
their light squares c4 so I'm already
looking to somehow get a piece here I
would like to get my bishop or Knight
their exchanged sacrifices comes to mind
I think I could also just capture but I
think I'm okay with keeping our grabbing
some space
and where's this taken ago
now I'm going to take some steps to get
my night here it's a long journey but
it's a static position so time not as
much of a factor if they challenge this
it's not without its weaknesses in fact
this is good for multiple reasons to
break down their kingside and redeploy
the bishop on this diagonal that would
definitely be a quick focal point rook
Bishop Knight and that's what we're
gonna have I guess so we chop here first
probably best to start with the knight
move
this is an excellent spot form I'm
thinking a bit less about this move
because of night here so probably just
chop
you
okay if am i okay with giving them this
file
take here - be careful of this square
and we're going to do this
this might be interesting actually
this on the other hand I'm gonna give
that up I have a better home for my King
and I think this is just a win because
of this move winning upon on the bishop
threatening this stuff
not quite
I think it's better to just take with
the night he's more essential now and
that's still no good because both our
queens are unprotected I got the Queen
where we stand there's less than 10 left
and that's putting me at third ooh
bayern is in there with 48 492 are in
here nice turnout for the daily super
blitz arena so yeah and this guy might
also pass me right on by he's in a game
right now let me take a quick peek at
that game how is he doing is he gonna
win team like and a win team white is
not going to win that
all right so he's gonna he should be
losing
still gonna play one more without a
bizarre berserk maybe berserk the last
148 okay we've been here already yeah
that came where my opponent dropped
their Queen after the F file opened up
okay well
that weakens their King let's take let's
insert this check let's see how they
block the Queen huh but I get a pun now
that's an important guy you take me I'll
take with the bishop let's develop
knight c6 I imagine let's go here and
extra pound that I have I'm going to try
to make his presence felt or mi
I'm actually going to take first if I
pushed here I think captures and then if
I recapture there's Bishop here I want
to get this move in and be able to shut
down the bishop soon
so let's do it
now let's do it right now put the bishop
here
yeah and probably just castle
and I could definitely be annoying
yeah where's my dark square bishop gonna
God I don't know here he gets pushed
around I guess here
scares me
I'll still still do that um
unprotected so I'm fearing this kind of
stuff opening up but I should be able to
weasel out of that somehow let's start
with this bishop here this
I'm just looking to make sure I have
some stability with my pieces so now we
challenge this rook still up upon
I could do this I want in this move and
then King to f2 and I'm satisfied
I could have also
about this move throwing a punch at that
poem which is probably best
but this doesn't hurt
this is still an improvement
here
I don't know it's probably a nothing
move but do something fast
let's just open it up a little bit
and ready to exchange one rook just
don't want to see this night cemented in
there so easily now let's jump in have
some nice squares IDE up check -
checking squares less than 40 I guess
we'll keep this rook around
no bother I'll return deaf too
still have this ID in mind and
discoveries on this square also this and
are we at that point yet
back off
let's shoot him away
that move
rook here I overlooked I can defend that
I have this covered
my bishop yeah they're ready to remove
the night
it's a little awkward
just a little awkward and here we go now
I'm untangling
new square for my bishop
and night is probably dead yeah this guy
could just pack up and run all right
where we have 46 with fire
they are in slipped up maybe I should
have berserk that last one
mm okay well we'll see how finished I
could probably I could be caught by any
of these two he's not applying
all right um one last game no need to
berserk this one let's see if we could
obtain a winning position in two maybe
my opponent resigns
otherwise this is probably just not
going to finish
neither one of us want to move the D
pons committal decision okay no no they
go in for that let's let's keep the
tension I'm allowing a space invader
pond
let's take once
and I didn't see that at the end this
guy was hanging
okay so interesting change of structure
and a play f4
hater but he's just going to have to do
I didn't play this because of a five and
I don't I wouldn't be able to maintain
the structure over here now that the
bishop has gone elsewhere maybe I don't
know queen h5 looks kind of appealing
what are they up to let's find out
hmm
feels right
Wow
sneaky sneaky sneaky sneaky
and I guess I have to give up that
square playing extra fast I probably
just have to get rid of them they do do
that
less than two
this is tough to come up with the plan
I think I have to do something like this
Bishop c1 next it's not fun to run it
like this that's for sure
I can't drop a tree though Wow okay
he just he just took a quick pit stop
there that's all and I'll come back over
here they're gonna try this probably
Queen ag2 to defend I'm looking at f4
let's go here
I could play rook h1 if they try a
battery
d efense
alright let's get my majority going now
the tournament's complete by the way now
he doesn't have to defend here now we're
looking at c5 next are they defending
that pawn I'm in a pin
oh it's
instead I'm in a pen whoops and they
they took that guy out really fast all
right I got a I got a go hunting they're
not giving me anything I need a new
square for my King Bishop here is
probably good can I get something
well think I have something they don't
have this move in yet
he's a bit out of play
it's getting kind of serious kind of
serious let's take one rock off okay
that move let's give a check they have
this move I didn't see that you have a
check I'll look here mm-hmm
let's take here and look for this stuff
is that serious
where's the mate maybe I could weave a
may even without a queen
cleanest a block oh and I could kick the
king away from the Queen that's good
enough
no stalemates you know I got made soon
all right well we got that last one it
wasn't enough to get podium lined but a
good tournament
56:54 48:46 is where i stand one five
thirteen and all
okay I am NOT going to go through all
the pages maybe just the top the top 100
let's see who the top 100 we're rocky
Balboa's in there
Serbian Knights old school future I see
dragon well
blue eagle
rating eater pots or chests and there we
go there's the top 100 won't go through
them all okay that was a good tournament
that was a good tournament okay to the
512 of you good games all
all right
you